liberal comedian Bill Maher continuing
to give his fellow Democrats some hard
truths as they slide further and further
to the left Marr is now comparing woke
progressives to the Ku Klux Klan given
their constant fixation on race
they believe race is first and foremost
the thing you should always see
everywhere which I find interesting
because that used to be the position of
the Ku Klux Klan again you can have that
position but don't say that's a liberal
position you're doing something very
different
okay Jessica Marr says that he's always
trying to make the case that liberal is
a different animal than woke which he
feels takes things too far to the left
Fringe do you agree with him well he's
drawing the distinction yes I do so
there's obviously a far left side of the
party and then there's the bulk of the
party which falls into this
establishment Camp which is your
run-of-the-mill Democrat but he's even
going further back and talking about old
school Blue Dog Democrats so you know
what was going on in the 90s during the
Clinton era and everyone has generally
updated their social positions for
instance on things like gay marriage
becoming more pro-choice Etc
um but Bill Maher is and I really enjoy
them I watch the show all the time
he's very disconnected from where the
Democratic party is today there are core
issues that make it so that he would
never vote for the conservatives
obviously climate change is a huge issue
for him but he says regularly Donald
Trump shouldn't even be allowed to run
for office because of what happened on
January 6th so this isn't
I don't know it's not the own that I
think a lot of people think that it is
when you know Bill Maher comes out and
says something negative about liberals
he's not turning into some sort of
conservative Scion
all right Greg 56 of Americans view the
term woke as positive now will that
number go down over time as they go more
and more to the left or to the
Republicans have to adapt well I think
that uh Jessica didn't realize she
self-owned her own party because you
said that he um you agree with the fact
that there is a different element to the
party that's awoke and then you say that
he doesn't identify with the bulk of the
party I don't think you can have that
both ways I think he's pointing out the
obvious but it needed to come from a
liberal because no one listens to us
right this guy was a progressive when
AOC was in diapers so the point is and
he's correct and he is very correct
because you have to credit you know
democrats for being in the civil rights
movement and you know the idea of
looking at everything through the prism
of race is indeed racist no matter what
direction you come from because if you
use race as a filter that means you see
people as groups and not individuals and
there can only you could that means you
can can only say that one group is
better than another because there's no
such thing as Equity or else there would
be 50 percent white guys in the NBA and
fifty percent black guys playing hockey
that's not the case and before anybody
says you know pretending race isn't a
factor in life it's impossible that was
the goal that was the whole damn goal we
built the system so we could reach that
goal it was called America we that was
the Melting Pot at some point we'd move
to a system where we didn't see skin
color but the woke's goal which is
equity making things Equitable is also
their system right
and if it's your system that means
somebody gets punished if you gotta if
if this group if you only look at them
as a group and not as an individual and
they do better than you
then you have to punish them whereas if
you just looked at individuals you'd
never have to do that that's why he's
right you're dealing with a racist
component of your of in your party and
it's as bad as the racist component say
in the right
baby worse
Jessica
do you want to respond to that Jesse
well in a way you're right electorally
the Democratic party used to focus more
on class and class divisions and then
they got wiped out a few times Barack
comes around and focuses much more on
racial Division and so did the academics
and so do the media people because you
create an oppressor and then you create
a victim and that helps them with their
interest groups when they're running
nationally but that's not really what
connects this country you have maybe a
black middle class guy from Georgia has
a lot more in common with a white middle
class guy than Tennessee than some
overly educated white Democrat from the
upper east side of Manhattan and that's
what they don't want to talk about
because if you unite this country
through class middle class people that
all agree that you know you guys are
crazy let's just go back to what works
the Democrats are in deep trouble you
know um Dana the the San Francisco
Chronicle talked about the Oakland
Elementary School District and saying
segregation of children for play dates
excluding white kids is a familiar
strategy used by the Republicans so what
they had were black Hispanic non-white
kids for play dates and uh the white
kids were excluded and they said well
this is what the Republicans do isn't
that hypocritical
I I don't have children so I don't know
about the play dates but when you read
this you think well there are you just
Echoes back to what Greg was saying that
well wait didn't we build this whole
system so that we wouldn't have to have
that and children don't see race so this
is more about the parents so and and I I
I read these things and I hear from some
of the black parents in this case saying
that we want our children to feel safe
and I'm thinking but why do the children
feel unsafe did something happen to them
and if so you know let's fix that but I
feel that we are taking several steps
backward what's interesting about Mar
Joe Rogan Etc is we're living through
this political realignment and I don't
know how it's going to turn out it's
very interesting to live through it
we're in the middle of it but now you
start to see people have access to
different mediums so they might be on
Tick Tock or some other social media or
they might be listening to a podcast
they might be watching here they might
be watching that word and you you
can find somebody who makes you go oh
that's what I think and if you hear that
you're going to listen to it over and
over again that's why I think Joe
Rogan's very popular that's why your
show is very popular in prime time and
why America's Newsroom is crushing it
obviously but I I do worry about the
fact that I think the parents are the
ones driving it because the children are
not the ones who are seeing color
remember Obama said that and the most
beautiful thing is my children don't see
that and if we teach them that then in
20 years what are we going to be facing
can I say
super quick about Obama
telling me we gotta go
I did hear that too but he didn't inject
race into it he injected a black man
into it and race came back at him people
then said he was an American that he was
from Kenya people still question those
kinds of things well you also were
accused of being racist for disliking
Obamacare
I don't all right coming up Burning Man
chaos thousands of Partiers and
celebrities left stranded in a muddy
mess I wanna Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now